we're told the following rectangle is
partially split into unit squares what
is the area of the rectangle Above So
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's do this together so
first it's good to just know what do
they mean when they say area
well they say it's partially split into
unit squares when they're talking about
a unit Square they're talking about a
square like this and when we're talking
about area we're talking about how many
of these unit squares would exactly
cover this entire shape that many unit
squares would be the area of this entire
rectangle so how could we do that well
what we could do is we could keep
drawing these lines that have already
been partially drawn and we can then see
how many of these unit squares we have
so let's just finish drawing these lines
here I'll try to draw it as neatly as I
can so we have that we have that like
there and then let me complete this one
and let me complete that one I'm almost
done that one and then that one
and so what we have here let's see how
many rows do we have we have one two
three four five rows
and in each of those rows let me do it
this way five rows
and in each of those rows how many
squares do we have Let's see we have one
two three four
so you could view it as we have five
rows of four so how many total of these
unit squares exactly cover this
rectangle well we could just count them
we could see that that is going to be
well it's going to be five rows of four
so it's going to be one row that's four
then another four then another four then
another four and then another four and
let's see yep I have five fours here I'm
adding the five rows of four each there
and what is that going to be equal to
well this is going to be equal to four
plus four is eight plus four is twelve
plus four is sixteen plus four is twenty
so the area of the rectangle above is
going to be 20 and it's important to say
20 of what it's 20 square units or maybe
I could say unit squares either way but
I'll call it square units and we are
done